MGM Resorts International responding
tonight after group of Casino Giants are
named in a class action lawsuit accused
of illegally raising room rates that
lawsuit filed in District Court this
week by Seattle Law Firm Haggins Berman
now the lawsuit argues companies
including MGM Resorts Caesar's
entertainment win and Treasure Island
among others are artificially inflating
hotel room prices and overcharging
guests the lawsuit claims those
companies used a revenue platform called
Rainmaker to monitor real-time prices
for their competitors so they could
adjust their rates and on the Fly and
maximize their profits now we reached
out to numerous casinos MGM Resorts
International responding the claims
against MGM Resorts are factually
incorrect and we intend to defend
ourselves vigorously against these
meritless claims